TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is "The
Developer Show."
I'm standing here with Purnima
Kochikar, Director for Google
Play Apps and Games.
Purnima, welcome to the show.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
Thank you, Timothy.
Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
great to have you here.
First, I'd like to learn a
little bit about your history
and what brought
you to Google Play.
I know that you used
to be VP at Nokia
for Developer Communities.
What is it that you learned
about developers there
that brought you to this role?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: What I loved
about working with developers
is that they are
always optimistic.
I don't think there's
any job in the world
that you're working with
more optimistic people who
are trying to solve
amazing problems.
Every day I talk to
people who are saying,
this is a new way of doing taxis
or a new way of doing education
or a new way of supplying food.
So there's always a new
way, and that's exciting.
The second thing, what
I love about developers,
is that they'll take the
technology or a platform
that you have built
and completely
use it in ways that you have
never imagined would happen.
And so the two aspects
of it, the surprises
and the solutions, is what
makes me excited about working
with developers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
one of my favorite things
too is that working
with platforms, we
always kind of an idea of how
developers are going to use it.
And then they always find
a way to surprise us,
especially with Google Play.
Because that the
landscape is so huge,
there's always something
every week where you're like,
that's amazing.
And I never would
have thought of that.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Yeah,
exactly, and so it's
amazing to be able to do this.
Plus you realize that you're
actually making a difference
in people's lives,
both for the developer
as well as for the user.
And so that helps too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's interesting
to talk about Google Play
because developers
who build in Android
already know about Google Play.
But sometimes I
wonder if they know
all of the kind of
nooks and crannies
and some of the best features.
Do you have like maybe some
of your favorite lesser known
features of Google Play that
are great for app developers
and publishers?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
Well, I don't know
whether it's a lesser
known features,
but maybe we should
talk about the things
that people may not think about.
Number one thing I believe
that people should really
think about is that
your users really
want your app to get better,
and you should tap into them.
I think a lot of times
I hear developers say,
there's a really bad review.
Can you make it go away?
And I'm like no, harness it.
Your user really cares.
So what can you do about it?
But they're also telling
you positive things.
So on Google Play, one of the
things we've really focused on
is to how to get
developers to harness
all the intelligence of the
users to make better products.
So everything from alpha beta
testing, to staged rollouts,
and now we just introduced
A-B testing, which we
call store listing experiments.
So harnessing the
intelligence of your users
who are your biggest
advocates and your users
to make apps better, I
think, is something people
don't use enough.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, and
we just mentioned an article
on the show about
ratings and reviews
in the Google Play
developer console.
And I think we've
done a lot of work
there to bring that intelligence
into a format that's actionable
and really like intelligible
at the same time.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Absolutely,
one of the big things
developers told us is that we
love the fact that we can reply
to reviews and that we
could have a direct channel
of communication to our users.
However, there are
so many reviews.
How do I find the themes?
How do I know in areas
that I should focus on?
And what I find
interesting is that there
are folks who will view it as
something as a problem to fix,
but a lot of people are now
looking at the strengths
that they need to leverage.
So they're looking
at it as a way
to measure community
sentiment management.
So what we did is to say
how do we measure sentiment?
And the tools we
are talking about
allow developers to
use Google smarts
to understand all the
hidden gems in your ratings
and reviews.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
Developers often ask me, and
I'm sure they ask you as well,
what's the secret?
And the coolest thing is you
actually recently published
a second version of "The Secrets
to App's Success on Google
Play," which you
should check out
and will be LinkedIn
the show notes.
However, maybe you can
give us a highlight.
What's one of your favorite
kind of insights from that book?
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
The first thing
we did was actually
put it out linearly.
So the nice thing about the
book is that you can always just
jump in where you are at the
stage of what matters to you.
So if you're in design, there
is a section for design.
If you are in place
where building growth.
there's a section for growth.
If you're thinking about,
should I use ads for monetizing,
there's a section for that.
It goes not just about
Android and Play,
but also looks at other
Google technologies, like ads,
for example.
So that's a huge plus.
So the big insight I
would like to point there
is to really think about what
it means to be not constrained
by the market that you're in.
Android is huge.
it's around the world.
And you could be
a global business,
no matter where you are.
This book gives you
interesting ways
to tie from
everything from how do
you design for various
markets, how do you localize,
but also how do you price.
So that I think is--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
really inspiring.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Yes,
I mean, think about it;
20 years ago, they would
have needed a new management
team to figure out how to
take a business global.
Now you could do it
from your living room.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And sales
offices in multiple markets,
whereas, again--
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Now you can.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
Thanks for joining me today.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Thanks
for having me, Timothy.
This was fun.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For more
information about everything
that we talked about, check
the show notes for links
and, of course,
subscribe to this channel
for more interviews like this.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.